[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
number one best-selling author and
ramsey personality christina ellis joins
me as my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and have incredible high
quality real relationships we're so glad
you're with us america open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five before we jump to the
phones we just wanna say thank you
to all of you america
you have uh given ramsey solutions yet
another number one bestseller dr john
deloney's book we found out late last
night is the number one bestselling book
in the nation on its launch week so
congratulations to dr john to the
marketing team
to the ramsey solutions folks and uh
but but thank you guys uh the reason
that works is is that we let you know
that
what dr john deloney has to say is
amazing and you believed us and you went
and bought the book
and we appreciate that we appreciate you
being customers we appreciate the
opportunity to serve you uh you folks in
every nook and cranny major metro market
in the united states have come around
and
been faithful to ramsey and all things
ramsey for many many decades many of you
and we're just thankful for you we
appreciate you and
this book is um is more than deserving
of this it is an exciting
exciting piece of writing all about the
not so complicated approach to
relationships
mental health and wellness own your past
change your future is the number one
christina yes
go dr john deloney i've heard nothing
but great things about this book and so
many people are just saying it's
changing their lives people who didn't
think they needed their lives changed
picked up this book and are just raving
about it so that's just amazing i'm so
proud of them well i'm always happy as
the owner of the company when i'm
reading through the manuscript and i get
choked up
so that always gives me a hint that this
thing's probably a hit right because if
you can get me
to you know i mean because i've kind of
seen it all done it all you know and
that kind of stuff so but this is this
is i'm going this is gonna this is gonna
this is good
it's good inside my brain it's good
inside my life and it's good inside
yours it's good inside other people's
own your past change your future
and uh the the lineup of people dr les
parrott pat lincione dr lynn jennings
craig groeschel michael dr michael gomez
dr mike meeker dr henry cloud that
endorsed the book is absolutely
incredible and again thank you you guys
out there no matter how good the book is
um
you know if you guys don't go pick it up
it it doesn't help you you don't get to
tell other people about it and it
certainly doesn't become a number one so
we did not cause this book to be a
number one you guys out there did by
buying it and uh by supporting john and
the efforts here and we just want to say
thank you and congratulations to
dr delony on his first major number one
book very cool stuff it's so needed and
so timely right now i feel like every
day i see an article about the mental
health crisis and this going on and
people feeling so much anxiety and i
just love this book empowers people to
take control they realize they don't
have to live there they don't have to
stay in anxiety they don't have to keep
struggling they can change their future
that's just you know what happened was
we got we got kicked in the kneecap
emotionally and in our mental wellness
and those of us that were pretty strong
or were medium strong we we got a sore
knee emotionally in our mental wellness
from the stuff we've all been through in
the last couple of years and so we need
a framework to
process that and we need some guiding
steps some things to do some guiding
principles
to uh do this now if you've got serious
mental uh
wellness mental health issues this is
not a book about that this is a book
like for regular people to be better
regular people hello you know have
better quality relationships better
things going on all right let's start
with ben today on this hour ben is in
chicago hi ben welcome to the ramsay
show
hey guys thanks for taking me on sure
what's up
hey quick question for you so i'm 37
i've uh got roughly about eight hundred
thousand and not worth
i'd like to be a millionaire by age
forty or will be as close as possible
so here's here's my question for you i
have
obviously a primary house
then i have two investment properties
and over the past couple years i've
accumulated approximately thirty
thousand dollars in
just loans credit card debt things like
that that i'm i just want to pay off
my question for you is
i should be able to pay this off in two
years which
i i believe that's what your book says
without having to sell any properties or
things like that
should i just try to pay it off in two
years keep the investment properties and
continue on with my plan
or should i sell one or both investment
properties
and pay off all my debt into a good
chunk at
my primary residence and pay off that
money yeah
okay
well the first thing occurs to me that
sounds weird is is that thirty seven
thousand dollars is such a big deal if
you have eight hundred thousand
what do you make
uh between my left man we make a round
two time a year
okay you don't have two years you got
one year
sure that's completely wimpy
that's completely wimpified
you make a lot of money pay off the
stink of debt man cut up your credit
cards you're sloppy
and we did yeah yeah we we took care of
the credit cards and uh things like that
out and my main goal is
you know i just want to pay off the debt
and
become debt free as soon as possible
yeah yesterday i didn't know the best
yeah
yeah i didn't know if the best option
were to sell an investment property to
kind of
jump start that or uh just continue on
with my plan and just stay after that no
i i will continue on your plan yeah with
that income i think you can definitely
tighten up your budget and get this paid
off quick and then you'll still have
those investment properties moving
forward to build wealth i think you all
are motivated and got that goal so just
get at it
so ben
here's what i think i'm hearing and you
can tell me i'm wrong and i'll accept
that okay
okay with your income which is fabulous
and how great a job you've done building
wealth
for this thirty seven thousand dollars
which is a very small number in your
world
to have snuck up on you and just
appeared there that feels like just a
level of disorganization
a level of
laziness
yeah no doubt yeah this last year we uh
you know we mailed it in
yeah exactly and we were spending money
that we didn't have yeah and you're just
like i can afford it and i can just buy
this
and you you relaxed and you kind of got
fat
exactly that's what happened to me
during covet by the way i ate every
donut in a 50 mile radius i got so fat
it was unbelievable
i put on i put on so much weight i i
mean i had to go i had to have a
doughnut ectomy it was awful
and so so i understand what you
understand what happened it's not i'm
not picking on you not like i don't do
the same stuff but uh but i think that's
what i'm hearing and so that's different
than
i mailed it in i was sloppy
lazy whatever we want to call it without
being too harsh because it really wasn't
that harsh it was just you know just
tighten it up dude and you know get back
to doing what you know how to do you'll
be done
that's a different prescription for you
than oh my god you're so out of control
and clueless because you're not right
you're not and
i just wanted yeah you don't need no you
don't need to sell those investment
properties you just need to get on
dadgum budget you and your wife get
together and go hey hey hey hey we're
not doing this anymore
right that kind of thing
right how does it do it to me i'd look
in the mirror and go listen you're fat
quit eating doughnuts galilee
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
well we've taught god's and grandma's
ways of handling money and life around
here at ramsey for over 30 years now our
good friend and ramsey personality dr
john deloney's paving the way for how we
talk about relationships and mental
health the new book own your past change
your future is available for purchase i
just mentioned
it's a number one bestseller as of
yesterday
every one of you listening needs this
you have a story
and you need to own your past
and change your future john's taking his
two phds and 20 years of counseling
experience and packed it into an easy to
understand book it's only 20 bucks
ramsey solutions.com
own your past change
your future grace is in los angeles hi
grace welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me dave
sure what's up
so my husband and i um we're in baby
step seven but we actually skipped baby
step five because we cannot agree
on how to execute baby step five
we have three small children and he does
not want to put money away for their
college
because
he's concerned that um
what if they don't do a four-year
college maybe we want the money more
liquid so they can use it for a trade
school or something else of that nature
they can use
they can use a 529 for trade school
you can use it for trade school but what
if well i guess he's concerned that he
gets locked in there and then what if he
just it's not locked you can take it out
there's just a penalty on you don't get
to keep all the growth tax free
you get to pay a tax on the growth you
pay a tax on the growth
but the principle you would be able to
keep
sure and you keep all the growth minus
the penalty for the tax for taking it
out and not using it for education
okay and it's transferable it's
transferable to siblings
okay so
what i guess what would you suggest we
do in this situation i mean do we
find i would suggest he gets some more
some better knowledge than he has which
will lead him to a different decision
that would be helpful
[Laughter]
well i mean he's making he's making us
he it sounds like he thinks it's stuck
in there and christina 529 you can get
two yeah there's a lot of options with
529s you can even use it for k through
12 expenses so if you notice that maybe
your oldest isn't going to college you
can switch beneficiaries and use it for
k through 12 use it on another one of
your kids educations there is a lot of
flexibility in it so i know it's kind of
scary because it seems so
concerning about if your kids don't go
to school but there's there's a lot you
can do with it
but worst case scenario worst case
scenario you just simply cash it out
and let's say that you had put in 50 000
and it grew to 100 000. i'll just make
up a number that wouldn't be right but
let's just say um let's just say you
know you made fifty thousand dollars
okay you're gonna pay taxes on
the fifty thousand dollars growth
or let's say you put
sixty thousand in and it grew to a
hundred that's probably more realistic
okay so you're going to pay taxes on the
growth if you cash it in and don't use
it for education
which you would have done if it was just
in a mutual fund by the way
okay
you have to pay taxes on if you put it
in a mutual fund you have to pay taxes
on it so
you know the the only thing the 529 does
is give you tax-free growth for
education so it's a roth ira for
education in a sense mathematically so
you can cash it out you get to keep all
the money you put in
all of the growth but you have to pay
taxes on it and a penalty on it like
cashing out an ira early
what is the penalty i
think it's 15.
10 or 15. 10 or 15. it used to be
it used to be 10 and then it went up and
i think it's come back down so i can't
remember but it's not
it's you you're you're going to get to
keep some of the growth and all of the
principle
which is all you would have got i mean
what you're going to lose here is the
penalty
versus if you had it in mutual funds so
it's worth it
it's worth a try okay so is it better
than in like an atma or yeah because in
atma you're going to pay taxes on once
it gets to a certain size
okay
that's what i use for my kids because
529s weren't there when they were little
there's no such thing so let's talk
about an atm because that's a really
good discussion thank you for calling um
an atma stands for utma uniform transfer
to miners act
in no case can a miner
under
18 years old do a financial transaction
of any kind they can't have a bank
account so if you go down and open a
bank account for your kid at the local
bank it's technically not in your kid's
name
it's technically an atma
it's technically has their name on it
but it has you as the custodian of the
account
because children are not allowed to do
contracts under contract law in america
okay
so you open a bank account you do
anything in a kid's name
16 years old you cannot you know you
can't do a contract it's not binding so
you go open a mutual fund in the kid's
name with you as the custodian that's
all an utma is now it's taxed at the
kids rate which is nothing
until the mutual fund gets big enough
that the income off of it is past their
deduction deductible
the standard deduction okay and so you
can get ten twenty thousand dollars in
there for your paying taxes on but then
you're gonna pay taxes on it so i paid
taxes on
the mutual funds that were in my kids
names once they got to a certain size
the kids did and so it ends up with less
money in the account
because i paid taxes
than i would have if it was in growing
tax free in a 529
and so there's really very little
downside of doing the 529 that's my
point that's why i was being smart i
like about it
and well so yeah you're right it sounds
like that it's a better value and then
if they just don't go to college because
my husband's gun shy his sister had 450
000
in student loan debt and so he's very
like you're not going to have any
student loan debt but
you know you're going to get you're
going to get scholarships and if you
don't go to college you know you're not
gonna if you drop out early or something
we don't want you wasting it so yeah
well you can pull it out
in the current environment with higher
education having lost
its shine
with the epic student loan crisis and
with how they've misbehaved during covid
like they're trying to charge full
tuition to do uh
e-learning from home and you don't even
show up
at the actual location and that they
want to charge full price and people are
going i don't think i'm paying that for
that
and so higher ed's kind of got a couple
black eyes right now and a lot of people
are going look there's a whole bunch of
people got a whole bunch of stupid butt
degrees that aren't useful at all and so
there's a lot of people worried about
you know maybe for your but i don't
think you ought to throw the baby out
with the bathwater i think there's a
valid use for higher education is it for
everyone no
uh and before i get a master's degree
for 250 000 in sociology i'm gonna go
get a welding certificate
and make three times what a sociologist
makes
okay and so uh you know that's you know
i'm with people on that but this idea
that all higher ed is bad we don't
believe that right yeah i would
challenge you all to take that fear from
the 450 and the bad experiences with
higher education and turn it into
motivation to save even more
aggressively for the 529 you know help
set your kids up for success have them
give that savings to them so that they
have it available plus inspire them to
go for scholarships like you said and be
really motivation motivated to own their
own journey to higher education yeah
you're right the the 450 000 in
debt should lead you the other way to
make you into a savings maniac right
right that is sisterhead so
yeah uh but i guess he just he's
paranoid about the whole
process now i get that i understand that
that's why i'm addressing it but yeah i
think there's very little downside
and um you know
and i do think there's a huge value to a
usable four-year degree
i i you know all three of my kids
four-year degrees sharon and i four-year
degrees um you know my
uh father-in-law is very very proud that
of his 13 grandkids 12 of them have
four-year degrees you know he's very
proud of that and he should be he should
be that's very good you know and so um
but but but again we're not for useless
degrees we're certainly not for student
loan debt
but uh but none of that's necessary so
all of that to say
we had college funds and we told our
kids from the time they were little this
is your college fund this is your
college fund this is your college fund
which presupposes that by god you're
going to college right you know it's
kind of like drilled in it's like a
little bit of a brainwashing thing here
you know so
yeah so i didn't have i wasn't ringing
my hands that they might not go because
i really wasn't giving them a choice
so i'm but i'm an old school dad that
way so that's the way that works
hey good stuff good stuff thank you for
calling ms grace that's a good question
i like talking about it
and we have the expert here christina
ellis to talk about it ramsay
personality joining me this hour on the
ramsey chat
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about
your
wealth building your work that you love
in real actual
relationships in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage ethan
and delaney are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you welcome where do
you guys live uh napoleon ohio it's
about a south hour half hour south of
toledo
okay not far from bowling green then
pretty darn close yeah yeah cool cool
well i actually have been to bowling
green a time or two and a good friend of
mine is from there scott hamilton okay
yeah the ice skating guy yeah cool well
welcome to nashville so
how much debt have you guys paid off
115 000 good how long did that take 17
months way to go and your range of
income during that time started around
65 and peaked around 205. whoa
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
nurse uh i'm an insurance agent what
happened to your income so when we first
started the journey delaney was not
working she was finishing up school oh
and then about three months and after we
we paid off our house but um that's what
the debt was but whoa
look at it
yes
but yeah so we started the journey about
three months or i'm sorry started
working about three months after we
started the journey to come okay cool
yeah and so lots of nursing available
huh yes i picked up a lot of hours i
could tell and knocked the house out
what's the house worth uh just over two
hundred thousand what do you got how old
are you two 27 26
and they paid for a house
that's incredible so impressive
what happened that got you all started
on this journey um it's kind of
interesting um we're going back to our
first date uh darnell four or five years
ago but we started talking we asked the
right questions on our first date
brought up dave ramsey talking about
finances and all that good stuff you two
are a couple of romantic yeah exactly
but uh ramsay on the first date
i didn't even talk about dave ramsey on
the first day exactly
but notice that that's kind of where it
started um we were both in the right
frame of mind and
started our marriage outright you know
followed the baby steps we both had our
own personal experiences of kind of
going through your program and seeing
how things worked um so kind of brought
up
right and then um
got married in 19 2020 july we bought
our first house wow um right in the
middle of cove in the middle of
covington why not
so right when delaney was finishing up
school she started working picked up a
ton of shifts
worked for both of us going really well
we knew it would probably take about
five to seven years like we had paid it
off early um but actually last year
around march or april around this time
we found out that delaney was expecting
yay
so girl's life is awesome oh yeah just
perfect so
no so we we kind of went through that um
we wanted to pay it off early it was
actually when delaney was coming home
from work after one of those long shifts
she said i think we can do this and you
know before the baby comes here it's
like yeah you're you're full of it you
know i didn't think we would be able to
um you know i'm the nerd i again i was
trying to crunch the numbers said i
don't know if this will work out but
um like i said delaney picked up a ton
of shifts i think people thought that
not that we were getting divorced but if
we were still together or not because
you know we'd hang out with friends hang
out with family um she would not be
there uh just because she'd be working
all the time so i have to give her a lot
of credit for that you just you just
game on girl
you're like you wanted that house paid
off with that baby yeah yep that was my
goal
i like it yeah i like it well that's a
nice thing though to be able to bring a
baby home to a debt-free house huh yeah
it's a different kind of feeling it
definitely is so it's scary enough to
drive with them in the car the most
we uh coming out for the hospital
actually it was funny we had a huge
snowstorm so
usually the drive would take about 40
minutes from the hospital to get home i
think it took an hour and a half i don't
know if that was the weather i think it
was the weather but it was just kind of
plus you were driving a wee bit more
careful than you usually a little bit
yes yeah y'all are such shining examples
you've done everything right what would
you tell people who think you know i
can't do this um this is too hard what
was the hardest part for you all
honestly i mean for me personally i
would say not seeing delaney um there's
a lot of sacrifices that you know we
both put in i mean more more of her just
picking up those extra shifts i mean i
think there were four or five bonus
contracts that
i mean spanning you know six weeks at a
time picking up extra shoes i mean she
was doing 60 65 hours a week minimum wow
pregnant while pregnant
i slowed down at the end where's your
superman cape girl i mean my gosh
but no she
is a big reason why we're here so we're
very lucky for her wow
who were your biggest cheerleaders uh
definitely our parents i think um like i
said dylan went through the experience
with her parents so i think they were
definitely big cheerleaders my parents
were big cheerleaders as well my
grandparents so
very cool well you guys have got an
incredible incredible head start yeah oh
my gosh no no payments of any kind you
own your house free and clear you're not
even 30 years old baby first baby's here
life is good two great careers i mean
you guys are in amazing shape yeah very
well done i'm so proud of you guys no
thank you so much dale such an honor to
meet you you're amazing very well done
what's next what's what's your next goal
you're so young you've got all this time
ahead we're just talking about i mean
we'd love to travel um maybe take a
couple of trips um we'd eventually like
to build a house um but just yeah just
kind of laying low and i mean it's nice
just not being able to have to talk
about money or anything like that i mean
we still talk about money but just you
know the issues that you know could
arise it's just our marriage is is great
um not that we struggled with that but
um no i just well she's home more now
that's right yeah for sure and i'm
part-time at that too so i mean when she
goes back actually going to be going
back here in a couple weeks
off from maternity leave but um she's
part-time and we're even debating
whether she'll go back entirely at all
so it's just
very cool that we can be at that point
in life though
i love it very very well done well we
got a copy of the number one bestseller
baby steps millionaires for you because
that's for sure the next chapter in your
story you are going there for sure my
goodness probably three or four years
you're going to be there it's pretty
amazing and also a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give to
someone and rock their world cause a
holy ruckus out there somewhere it's
kind of what we do around here so thanks
for that you guys are incredible very
very well done all right are we going to
put baby in the shot we have to right
so how old is
tell us about
this is mccoy he's three almost three
months old so like three months old
mccoy way to go dude yeah made actually
the last house payment uh two weeks
before he was born yeah so wow perfect
he's so amazing he has no idea how great
his parents are you guys are awesome man
you've changed your family tree what a
great shot we can just sit here and look
at this
norman rockwell right here man i'm just
telling you wow amazing well we won't
make him cry you yell as loud as you
want to yell but you're not required to
make him cry that's not our goal here
ethan and delaney from the toledo ohio
area and mr three-month-old mccoy yeah
115 000 paid off in 17 months making 65
to 205 lots of overtime house and
everything they're not even 30. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one where's that free
[Applause]
yes
this is how it's done
and if you can get that kind of start
if you can get that kind of start oh my
gosh right what a fantastic example
that's incredible
yeah you you know it and
you know there's always
you know i spoke to a group of high
schoolers this morning uh local in our
area here i went by as a favor to a
friend of mine
that's the teacher and he teaches our
high school curriculum and has since it
began
and um
really sharp
high schoolers but i i mean i'm talking
to them and i'm thinking
you know this is so hard
this life thing and this is so easy
this life thing you know if you can just
work i mean delaney got figured out you
should how you fix this i just work well
you're pregnant yeah well i just work
you know well i mean i want my house
paid off you know i know only one
where's money come from
work
you know work
work
you know just work it's just it's a
thing isn't it yup
wow it's impressive i feel so much
inspiration from this young generation i
feel like often people just gen z or
millennials and then you have people
like this show up on the debt-free stage
and just prove such a great example it's
so inspiring and exciting because it
shows it can be done no matter what your
age is well that's exactly right and and
you're right i do get inspiration it's
like you people out there that are you
know the old people like get off my lawn
people or whatever you know all you want
to do is trash this other generation i
got news for you there's some deadbeats
in every generation and there's some
rock stars in every generation and these
people they're rock stars in this
generation we see them all the time
america our culture is in good hands
when it comes to the quality of young
people we're seeing coming through here
every week and the stuff they're doing
how mature they are how smart they are
how hard they're willing to work you're
gonna be okay out there boys and girls
it's gonna be okay
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
christina ellis
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us open phones at
825-5225
we appreciate you being here nathan is
with us nathan is in omaha nebraska hi
nathan how are you
hey dave pretty good how are you sir
better than i deserve what's up
i love that answer uh longtime listener
i just wanted to get some advice in
regards to a collection company yeah the
most fun people on the earth to deal
with anyways uh got a letter in the mail
uh basically saying that hey notifying
you this is the law office uh we're
gonna sue you if you don't respond
within 20 days over a past due credit
card bill for 625 bucks all right
i was able to get a hold of the date
negotiated a little bit lower discount
rate with monthly payments
here's where it gets a little sticky
they when i asked them okay how do i
submit the payments you guys want to use
a debit card for auto pay you know
whatever they said we don't accept card
payments okay so i figured okay is it
just over the phone or you know do you
have a website no no they don't have
debit card payments at all period the
only way that you can send in payments
is via check in the mail or on the
website or over the phone providing the
writing number and account number for
your checking account
now they did give me an alternative
which was mailing in a money order but
doing the math there it wasn't again not
a very large balance uh got it knocked
down from 625 down to 550. why don't you
just pay it just count
well my household income after tax is
1600 my expenses are about 13.
okay have a garage sale this weekend and
pay it
i don't have much to sell off i even got
rid of my car about six months ago
because i got a nice little work from
home
job so you don't own a vehicle
i do not no i decide i just had to
actually sell it um to pay off some
other student loan debt so i had about
four and a half grand still with my
associates that i paid off in full buy i
sold my car
in omaha nebraska
yes sir
how do you get around
i work from home i have
i know but you have to leave home
occasionally like go the grocery store
or
yeah so i go to the grocery store just
by picking i literally live about maybe
an eighth of a mile away from my local
grocery store they're open till midnight
just go over there grab what i need
every couple of days and just carry it
home okay what do you do for a living
uh so i actually work for the billing
department for a pretty big hospital in
the state of tennessee
um i'm not going to mention who they are
that's okay your job sucks
yes
it's not fun yeah you make no money
yeah
and that's the problem i mean you have
an income crisis
and it's reflected in the fact that you
can't even cover a 550 bill that's
laying here i'm not picking on you i'm
just telling you look there's two sides
to this equation the outgo side the
income side you can't cut expenses far
enough to prosper on sixteen hundred
dollars
yeah
so you've gotta do some things to get
your income up that probably involves
you saving up some money and getting you
a car so that you can get around and go
make some money
because you need some money
so uh that i would change your strategy
overall is what i'm saying now as far as
these people go just call them back and
tell them you're not gonna be able to do
it right now
just tell them jump in the creek
you don't need money there's nothing
they can get you don't have anything
yeah
you know i don't have any money and when
i get some money i'll call you and just
make you a settlement offer and we'll
just work it out i'll send you one check
but and then go about the business of
getting your income up and get some
money together and then do it in one
lump sum we do not recommend doing
payments with these goobs because once
they've got your bank information
they're going to clean your butt out and
you're going to be a problem because
they you can tell a credit card
collector's lying if their mouth is
moving
yeah
um so what i do about this whole court
summons things because right now there's
not a court summons they just threatened
you yeah they hadn't actually sued you
yeah
meaning they lied
okay they're gonna sue you someday but
they're not gonna sue you before you get
yourself listen a year from now you
can't be sitting where you're sitting
you understand that right oh yeah well i
actually got another job offer it's a
standby offer for for a
claims processor with an insurance
company and that it should be starting
if the position becomes available
somebody fails
i'll be getting that job started here in
about a month and a half and that's
going to be about a 35 yeah 35 increase
for my um with my current income so
well i think with this amount of money
this 625 which is now 550 you can make
that amount this weekend like you can go
around the neighborhood see if you can
mow lawns offer to paint someone's house
even go to target and get a job this
weekend and work for the next few weeks
like you can tackle this pretty quickly
i even got to play going to the local
platform center and donating some class
with knock out cause
you know hook me up to the machine stick
a needle on my arm and help save a lot
and get paid for it so i thought about
even doing that
well i i that's okay to do if you want
to do that i i i don't ever tell people
to do stuff i wouldn't do because i
don't do that but um i've done almost
everything else that was legal and moral
to go make some money so christina's
right go make some money and pay this
thing and then here's the deal do not
give them any money unless it's in
writing and never give them your bank
information under any circumstances
because they lie
they will take 625 out of your account
after you have in writing and promise
that it's 5.50 and you're not going to
sue them for 200 bucks and they know
that yeah exactly that's that
they're freaking crooks
okay 99 of them they're horrible
companies we work with them all the time
and they're just horrible so no you
cannot trust them and if you're out
there and you work you're a credit card
collector and you don't like what i'm
saying then go get a good job and then
you can like me so because your job
sucks so don't do this so anyway yeah
christine is right go make some money
clean this mess up and do it in one lump
sum and you can send them a money order
you can send them a prepaid debit card
they'll take that believe me if it's a
lump sum one time but do not give them
access to your checking account
ever
in an adversarial situation like this
and do not give them any money until you
have it in writing and you keep a heart
print if it's an email print it off keep
a hard copy with a copy of the receipt
where you sent the money stapled to it
in a file for the rest of your life
because they'll come back around they'll
forget
or joe that used to work here didn't
have authority well toughies i got it in
writing
and you have you but you can't be like i
i don't remember who i talked to now you
got to have it in writing
and you got to have the receipt stapled
to it for the rest of your life
but the good and the bad news is is that
you have a
old credit card debt the good news is
it's only 500
right yeah you can get this out of your
life quick get these people behind you
these people are shady this is stressful
you want to knock this situation out as
quickly as possible and like dave said
keep records like you just want to make
sure these people don't come around and
try to haunt you again
i bet you there's a lot of stuff you
could do in 48 hours that's legal
and moral that would make that kind of
money i mean you just put your head to
it out there your point that's
absolutely valid i love that all right
patrick is in columbus ohio hi patrick
how are you
hey how's it going dave
better than i deserve what's up
sure my question is so my company i'm on
a pension but they just started offering
a 401k too and it has a rough 401k good
so i have where i can pick my retirement
what age i want to be when i retire i
have the you know the target date and
then i have where i can actually pick
so
i was wondering when i'm actually going
to pick my mutual funds do i go lifetime
of the mutual fund or only go back like
10 years because lifetime is about eight
and a half and then at 10 years it's
sitting around like 11 or 12
either one's fine i mean you've got a 10
year track record of 11 or 12. it's
probably a fine fund
there's nothing wrong with that
um okay i would not use target dates
target dates adjust the portfolio
without your input
based on uh
you know
asset allocation theory which i don't
believe in
okay okay i don't adjust my portfolio i
just keep investing
i'm 61 i'm investing in the same things
i was investing in when i was 31.
because they work i don't need to adjust
it
um you're getting old i don't care i'll
just keep investing you know it's a lot
because it works
so and
if i'm 61 there's a high probability
when i'm 91
30 years from today that i'm gonna need
some money so i need to keep investing
aggressively um so yeah pick the four
funds that we talk about don't use
target dates and yes a ten-year track
record is just fine
work for you yep that works for me that
sounds great all right good stuff
christina ellis ramsey personality my
co-host today
james childs in the booth finn on the
board and kelly in the booth and zach
hiding behind the monitor i'm dave
ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and live with amazing real
relationships not virtual ones
and it's working we're glad you're here
america christina ellis best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
building wealth doing work you love and
high quality relationships we're glad
you're here triple eight eight two five
five
two two five
all right so there is a lot of data
heading out there this rel relations
from fox business americans are quickly
losing confidence
in the u s economy
according to a new survey published this
week reflecting heightened concerns
among consumers about sky-high inflation
and the rising price of everyday goods a
gallup survey published wednesday shows
americans have low levels of confidence
in the economy what's more most
americans expect the economy to
deteriorate
further
about 76 said the economy is getting
worse
compared to 20 who believe
it is
improving
so christina what we have to do when we
see stuff like this is there's three or
four things going on as far as i'm
concerned
thing one is
there is some real inflation
thing two is is not gonna kill you
it's bad it's ugly when you fill up your
car and you have a heart attack when you
look at the price
it's ugly when you consider that house
prices are doing what they're doing in a
lot of areas
it's not gonna kill you
i don't like it i don't want it to stay
around i don't think it's going to stay
around that's thing
one thing two is the news media
particularly our friends at fox
uh want to tell you over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again how bad the economy is
because if there's one thing that will
get a politician thrown out of office
of either party
it is that the economy is bad
so if you want to dump all of the
democrats in the street at the midterm
the best way to do that's convince
everyone that the economy is bad
so there's a little bit of an agenda
here
just a wee bit
and so yes the economy is bad and yes
there's some things going on but it you
know
the news media left and right and
confused whatever they are
they make all of their viewership based
on fear porn
if we can make you afraid of covid and
think you're gonna die
if we can make you afraid of the economy
and just keep peddling the fear porn
it you will keep dialing in you can't
stay away from it you can't take your
eyes off the train wreck
and so then your
adrenaline spikes your
uh
chemistry and your body starts changing
your heart rate changes your eyes dilate
you stay pissed off all the time or
afraid all the time and and it keeps you
coming back it's the same thing as a
tornado warning by the oh god the
weather people
so uh when i was a kid we were like oh
there's a tornado and now we shut down
schools because there might be a tornado
three weeks from now
so uh it's a different world but it's
that there's a little bit of all that
going on
uh so you know when you hear that the
economy is bad or that americans have
lost
confidence in the economy our message
would be um
yeah it sucks right now but it's okay
yeah well i think even going with the
analogy of a storm if there's a
hurricane coming what do you do you
batten down the hatches you make sure
everything is in place and solidified so
i hope people can take that kind of
uneasy feeling they feel in their
stomachs when they see that news article
when they see the fear porn and they go
you know what we need to make sure our
financial house is in order we need to
really make sure we're on a budget that
we're paying off our debt and we're
saving for an emergency because you know
if something does happen the more you
have your financial house in order the
less of a hit you'll take and that's why
your book is called financial peace we
want you to feel at peace regardless of
what the storm looks like yeah so the
good news about the storm is you can use
it as a warning to get your crap
together right
the bad news is you don't want to
overreact
and because people go cray-cray when
they go down these rabbit holes i mean
they just
when you're in panic mode your critical
thinking skills shut down
panic mode is run right and you know
your brain says get out of the way of
the car you're getting ready to be
smashed right and you're not supposed to
have a critical thinking about oh i
wonder what that fender will do to my
left leg you know we don't want to have
a discussion about this get out of the
dead gum road you know but that's what
that's your brain is designed to do that
lonely talks about that all the time
so the thing is this guys when you start
seeing the stuff on the news
just kind of take it with a grain of
salt some of it is politically driven
some of it is if we can keep you upset
we can keep you as a viewer
and some of it is real
and you kind of gotta parse through that
a little bit and go okay yeah gas is
really five dollars and that was really
biden on biden's desk he really screwed
this whole energy thing up bad
uh oh yeah uh supply chains all screwed
up and that drove prices up on a bunch
of stuff wasn't biden's fault he didn't
do that he didn't cause the pandemic and
he didn't cause a supply chain mess up
after the pandemic could he have done
some things to help probably but he
couldn't have stopped it from happening
some of this stuff is just the result of
it's a it's the aftertaste it's the
tsunami that came ashore after the
earthquake at sea
and uh that that's some of that is
what's going on there but the energy
stuff's 100 on him he just screwed that
up course he has no idea but in the name
of being woke or left or
energy free or whatever i mean or
whatever he's trying to do you know get
everybody in to buy an elon musk car or
whatever he's trying to do
um
he's you know he's screwing up
the economy because here's the thing
gas doubling
goes into the truck that delivers the
bread
and into the price of the bread
therefore
okay so this is a problem so yeah so
he's contributing to it so yeah he's
gonna get his party thrown out for
various reasons and that's
probably a great thing so it's okay it's
gonna work out but the point is you
cannot read these articles and go into
freakout mode
absolutely not yeah you gotta really
focus on the controllables you know what
can you control you can't control
macroeconomics of the us government you
can't control whether gas prices are
more expensive next week but you can
control your budget you can't adjust
things as necessary so that your family
can afford your lifestyle and you can
afford the things that you need to pay
for focus on the controllables yeah
i'll never forget watching a local
weather forecaster
and her voice was going up the octaves
were going up have you earned this it's
not like a beagle chasing a rabbit right
i mean she's just going crazy there's a
tornado coming
you know and and i swear the woman said
if you have a football helmet
put a football helmet on and go sit in
the
shower if you don't have a safer place
to hide
and so somewhere i've got visualize this
redneck sitting in a shower with a
football helmet on because this woman
said to do this and i'm just thinking
this is out of control guys you know
you know if a tornado hits your trailer
football helmet in the shower ain't
gonna cut it it's just not gonna i mean
it's just not gonna work
i mean i may or may not still wear the
football helmet but
unbelievable all right so this is the
world we live in though and so you have
to keep my point is you have to keep
your widths about you and make good
solid decisions yes you've got five
dollar gas
yes house prices are out of control
right now and so what do you do i mean
used cars are going up what kind of
world do we live in you know so
so is right now a good time to buy a
used car no it's a horrible time to buy
you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
we got the football helmet down off the
shelf because she's convinced me that
she's the one that would wear the
football helmet in the event of a
tornado while i would be outside looking
for the tornado
i may or may not have one for me and the
kids
you may or may not have oh we have
tornado helmets at your house yes we do
i got them from my babies i got them for
the husband except for my husband is out
in the street searching for the tornado
you really did do that you're not you're
not joking are you
no
true confessions true confession in
front of 2 million 20 million people you
just told people you have a tornado
helmet for your kids in my defense the
last tornado i don't think there's any
defense for this
i live in tennessee what can i say
there's a lot of things you could say so
do i
well the good news is is that we have a
very diverse group of ramsey
personalities we have the football
helmet-wearing ones and the non-football
helmet-wearing ones in the event of a
storm so um now you get advice across
the board
hey be prepared y'all be prepared be
prepared
yeah
buy a house with a basement oh my god
dig a storm cellar at least you'd be
safe the football home is a joke oh my
gosh
i have tornado helmets for my children i
don't know christina i i probably should
have known this before i hired you
hey we don't have a basement yet we
don't have a basement yet you sold your
house you're homeless what are you
talking about right
oh i love it just too fun all right
lexie is with us in iowa hi lexi welcome
to the ramsay show
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so my husband and i have been looking at
a piece of land outside of our town for
a while now long-term goal is to build
and have a little hobby farm and garden
for our three young girls
um so this past year my neighbor's house
sold for a lot more money than we would
have expected and so that kind of gave
me the courage to contact the landowners
of that really beautiful piece of land
we want and they're actually willing to
sell to us um so it kind of all happened
you know in an incident and now we're
kind of caught up what do we do
um to purchase this land i'd want us to
sell our house and live in my parents
rental house to save some money before
building but my husband's larry that
would get stuck there for land or
housing market prices so do we sacrifice
and move twice and go through lots of
hassles to get our dreams faster or
should we kind of slow down cool the
jets and just try to save where we're at
[Music]
uh so how much is the land
the land is 100k and how much is your
house going to sell for
it would sell for 410 around the world
we owe 250.
okay what's your household income
around 170 000.
why would you not buy the land and
start construction immediately with a
construction loan
because i just don't want to um have to
pay for a house payment and you're
paying a harsh payment now
i know it's just scary it's a lot of
money i'm saying sell the house sell the
house i'll sell it go rent something
start construction on the new house
buy the land
start construction on the new house and
move in in a year
okay yeah i guess i'm just hyper
sensitive to save save save and be as
comfortable as we can be because that's
my husband's fears i will get stuck in
my parents rentals
well your husband's right and because
you're being
so here's the thing okay you get 200 out
of your house did i get that right
yes sir okay put 100 on the land get
another 100 for your house
okay and then uh so what price range of
home would you build
uh we would say like three to four
hundred okay so let's call it three
hundred you put a hundred down you got a
two hundred thousand dollar mortgage you
got a two hundred thousand dollar
mortgage now what's your problem
i know you're so right okay thanks we
needed a third party so i could get my
uh football helmet off
[Laughter]
well if you if you if you do a 400 or
300 thousand dollar house 400 000 house
instead
you're going to be up 100 in mortgage
you have a 300 000 mortgage with 170 000
income which is still okay
okay all right thank you so much but
here's the thing okay
uh what you want to do is you want to
get these things lined up you're you're
now a project manager
and the project is
get into the brand new house on the land
okay now what are the elements of the
project and this line up the dominoes
and then push them all at once okay so
i'm not putting your house on the market
today
i'm gonna buy the land with as long a
closing out there as i can
how far away can i make the closing
as long as they'll let you six months
a year i don't care okay
then i'm going to start drawing
i'm gonna have it under contract
no contingencies we're going to close on
it i'm going to start drawing the thing
getting the builder getting construction
on all lined up and then i'm going to
sell your house and go
and let the dominoes all fall down we
break ground we start we close on the
land we break ground on the new house
everything's all done but you you can't
just say okay i'm gonna go buy the land
and close on it today
you haven't sold your house you can't
close on today and you can't
then take a year drawing the house and
another year finding the builder
right i didn't even think about pushing
out the closing thumb so it's under
contract at least and it'll give us a
little bit of time as long as you can i
mean so that you can get the plans drawn
get the construction loan lined up the
builder lined up and then you go sell
your house close on the land start start
the new house boom push down so i can
save that's why we push it out yeah well
you know
while you're doing all this you can save
even more yeah
yeah do you think it's okay for them to
live with her parents temporarily
they're not in with her parents it's a
rental house okay get a rental you know
it's her parents rental house right yeah
yeah you're not living with your mom and
dad right
heck no that would never
speaking of football helmets
exactly
yeah so it's just they own a rental
house they'll let you live in for free
for a little while
yep and your husband doesn't want to get
stuck there and his fear of being stuck
there is brought on by your penchant for
freezing everything you saved up all the
money
yeah he's not dumb yeah and so his fears
are valid
uh not because it's a fear of the
situation but he's gonna he's afraid
you're gonna freeze up and he's not
gonna get you to start this house
right so if you want if you want this
all to go down you're gonna have to line
up the dominoes and then he's gonna be
okay because you literally could be in
the new house in 14 months from today
assuming your builder is efficient you
don't try to build the taj mahal
you know
but you might not be able to get that
efficiency with supply chain issues
and uh
i don't know it also depends on how many
helmets you have to buy
because they're in short supply out here
we already got ours so we're good you
got you got yours you're good okay okay
just making sure you're covered here
christine
we're prepared we're ready
i love it this is too much fun
way too much fun
all right imagine the energy of a
jam-packed arena filled with people
ready to experience what it means to
live life to the fullest picture all of
your favorite speakers together on one
stage empowering you with the tools the
principles that will create unstoppable
momentum in your life that
is smart conference smart conference is
back
it's been three years and we are so
pumped to get this event going
christina will be speaking george
campbell
rachel cruz dr john deloney ken coleman
me
craig and amy groschel from life church
will be doing a session on marriage
we're going to talk about leadership
money personal growth mental health
relationships your career
all of it's going to happen
it's october the 22nd in dallas it's all
day long and if you come to the smart
conference at the end of the day you
will be smart
that's why we called it that
so check it out guys it's only 39 we
should charge 339 for this it is a
incredible lineup an incredible full day
event you cannot beat this go to
ramseysolutions.com get your tickets
before they are gone
it is not yet sold out it is in october
but it will sell out and it will sell
out
early
so uh be sure guys that you get this
done smart conference it's gonna be fun
christina i'm so excited i can't wait
i'll pay you double if you'll go on
stage with a football helmet
it's a no-brainer this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
i am dave ramsey your host in the lobby
of ramsey solutions on the debt-free
stage keith is with us hey keith how are
you i'm doing wonderful how you doing
dave better than i deserve sir and here
to do a debt-free scream how much have
you paid off ninety thousand dollars two
hundred twenty dollars wow and how long
did this take you three years and eight
months three years and eight months very
good and your range of income during
that time started at 62 000 and cleared
this year at 94 000. cool what do you do
for a living i am an auditor for the
state of pennsylvania all right cool
good for you good for you so the t-shirt
says debt free since 2021
yes so i completed my debt-free journey
in november uh the shirt was actually a
gift my one side hustle was i was i was
was a delivery driver for chick-fil-a oh
okay and my
the operator there bought this shirt or
got this shirt for me after i finished
so shout out to chick-fil-a linda road
in harrisburg mr brad thank you for the
support you know while i was working
there delivering god's chicken i love it
jesus chicken got me out of debt i like
it he's good man good for you man
very cool what kind of debt was the 90
000 a little bit of everything you know
car loan medical debt credit cards you
know irs debt a little bit of everything
yeah okay what made you decide to do
this three years and eight months ago
well it truly started in 2017 i was
going went to church and heard fpu you
know being advertised
and i took the class 2017 and
you know i was very dave-ish for the
first 14 months in fact
towards the end of the year you know my
car broke down and instead of
fixing it i ended up financing car so
you know that's more than ish that's
just not at all it was stupid yes it was
and then in
you know march of 2018 i got an email
from my coordinator after i took the
class asking
who wanted to jump in and help lead
i'm like i need a kick in the pants so
you know let me get in
since then i've now led 11 fpu classes
whoa so i lead them at lcbc in
harrisburg yeah yeah you're in there
spoke yeah wonderful pastor you guys got
a great place yeah i was there when you
were when you spoke and then was there
at the event afterwards when you and
chris spoke yeah yep that was a lot of
fun yeah very cool man 11 classes thank
you yes sir well nothing make you do it
like leading it right that is exactly
right i mean and it's so much fun when
i'm leading it to be able to tell
everybody look i'm working the same plan
it works
you know you can show the debt free
screams all you want you're gonna you
know show everything on youtube all you
want
but to be able to live it out and show
everybody that's you know the most
powerful thing that's amazing so you're
constantly leading people through this
what do you tell people is the key to
getting out of debt
uh you know i always hear people say
that the budget's key you know and
everything but to me the biggest key was
having a strong why
which is my daughter's
you know i have a 16 and 18 year old
daughters and
you know
before i started this i'm gonna count my
full-time job and my finances were a
wreck it was embarrassing
and i wanted better from them and my my
oldest to be a senior as a senior right
now graduates
soon going off to college in the fall
and i knew if i was going to get there
i had to clean everything up so you know
they're my driving force and everything
i've done
yeah where'd it go man thank you
congratulations thank you how's it feel
to be free
it feels so good i won i made that last
payment
you know both my daughters were there
their best friends were there and as
soon as i hit the button you know
everybody cheered and
i just felt like so such a relief off my
shoulders now my paychecks come in
they go into my savings i can do things
i haven't done in years i mean back down
here to travel to nashville and hang out
with a bunch of friends so yeah so
what's the story on this posse
for a couple days here yeah i've met
everybody a couple times and there's you
guys have quite a thing going what is
the deal here so
you know back in 2017 you know a bunch
of people were like i think was
mentioned on the show you should start a
dating site well
some people took that and ran we have
two different facebook groups for
singles who follow your principles oh my
gosh so you know one is dave ramsey
online dating i have followed dave
ramsey followers online dating and dave
ramsey dating group
so we've got about 2 500 members in each
group i am not responsible for anything
that goes on in this website
oh my gosh because i'm certainly not
getting a commission on it either from
what i can tell yeah you know we charge
huge fees the whole thing and nothing so
yeah okay well i get a percentage of
that okay good
so yeah i mean we so this is some of
that gang yeah this is some of this gang
that's some of my biggest besides my my
kids these are some of my biggest
supporters obviously they came in from
everywhere i know and i've told them the
last couple days how much i appreciate
it you know to be able to
you know being a single dad and being
able to do this kind of stuff you need
support i mean i've got support from my
kids my friends at home my church
but having a bunch of people like this
that are like-minded and following the
principles
and also struggling through you know a
single life or dating it's it's such a
encouragement and help
yeah because it's wild out there man it
is it's crazy and
community
having community around you when you're
doing it doing life period but doing the
whole financial thing it's just
necessary yeah absolutely
so what's next
uh the next thing is you know
looking to possibly buy my buy the house
i've been renting the last four years
uh looking to send my daughter to school
debt-free you know we've
she wouldn't take fpu when we had the
huge you know push at church but i i'm
like fine i'm just going to pound the
principles into your health into your
head at home
so that's what i've done and it's
my oldest like her one class she had
this year i think was foundations at
school so she was the teacher's dream
she knew all the answers oh man and she
comes home she comes home telling me how
stupid some of the kids are because
they're fine with debt like
like all right something's sinking in so
hey this is working i like this plan
very cool so cool i just i love seeing
your community over there and the way
they're smiling and beaming it really
does just show well i mean they've been
hanging around here a couple days
they're all having fun i mean it's it's
a it's a fun group oh we're having a
blast
we may be back tomorrow we haven't
decided yet okay well come on i mean
you're more than welcome the cookies are
still free and they're still delicious
so
it's all good well you guys have been
fun it's been fun talking to all of you
at the breaks and everything and uh now
that i know the history on the whole
thing it makes more sense yeah yeah it
was kind of random before well there was
there was a group of us down here in
2018 also yeah so yeah i mean we had
back then we actually had shirts made up
and everything that had different
slogans on them and everything so
you guys are a little scary oh we're
very we're very scary it's all good
very scary but very supportive
i'm kidding with you it's all great man
i'm so proud of you thank you and i am
proud of your gang hanging out with you
and supporting you that makes a huge
difference you can do so much more when
you got people that are walking with you
and holding you up when you're when
you're weak and smacking you around when
you're trying to do the wrong thing you
just got people that love you in your
life man it's just a good thing loving
enough to tell you what you need to hear
not what you want to hear amen very good
stuff we're very proud of you thank you
very well done we've got a copy of every
day i'm sorry
almost called it everyday millionaires
baby steps millionaires that book i
wrote there it is yeah baby step
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
and uh that's your next chapter in your
story for sure my man without a doubt
keith that's where you're going and copy
a total money makeover you can give it
away in your class maybe maybe as a
reward for somebody doing something
thank you so much for leading so many
fpu classes it's rewarding but it's uh
it doesn't happen without people like
you doing it well thank you it's amazing
the fun the fun thing i like to do
during my classes is we put out a jar
throughout the nine weeks and i tell
everybody if you feel led to leave a tip
you know go for what we'll do in week
nine then with the outrageous generosity
yeah we order pizza and then everything
we've collected in that tip jar we
tipped the delivery driver oh fun so
like this last class we tipped two or
three hundred three hundred dollars to
the delivery driver
so
it's delivery drivers going hey if that
church thing comes up again i'm gonna
take the pizza yeah that's why i try to
move it around so they don't anticipate
it's what's going on so
that's good very cool good stuff man
good stuff all right keith from
harrisburg pennsylvania 90 000 paid off
in three years and eight months making
62-94 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
well done sir
very well done oh man that's so much fun
how great is that
very very cool yeah the look on his face
i like felt that in my soul
amazing good
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis best-selling author
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jackson is in
tampa florida hi jackson how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve what's up
hey got a question regarding the
mortgage i know you guys talk about um i
have no debt and uh i know you talked
about putting 15 percent towards
investments and then the rest going
towards your mortgage
my wife and i are my wife and i are
incredibly risk tolerant
lost about 50 000 in our mutual funds
over the past month
and still just sold my car invested that
money straight into the stock market
because they're on sale
um so i know well i think that the math
says investments you're obviously a very
successful man so i'm not going to argue
with you but i'd like to genuinely know
why why do you go with that approach
versus the investments if you're risk
tolerant
well
risk tolerance has to do with what your
emotions
will allow you to do without going into
freakout mode
sure okay um and so uh
someone who has a very low risk
tolerance
can become a poor investor
based on the fact that their low risk
tolerance causes them to not take enough
risk agreed
someone who has too high a risk
tolerance can cause them to be a poor
investor
because they take risky investments that
end up losing more than they make
because they live out on their heads
yeah i'm i'm like i'm 99 mutual funds
i'm one percent in football helmets so
like i'm i'm in
i mean
for the score stock market for the score
i like it oh this is so good we have a
new measure of things this is awesome
born on the air today i love it that's
jackson jackson you get the award regard
you could go do whatever you want after
that so no i'm kidding all right so uh
uh
yeah but my point is okay so i grew up
in the real estate business and one of
the things you do in the real estate
business is they take your risk meter
and they break it with a hammer real
estate people have complete risk
tolerance we're idiots we're idiots we
don't even know there's risk
okay and that's what caused me to go
broke
because i was not measuring risk so
here's the here's what ends up happening
debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
less debt equals less risk
uh it adds risk to the portfolio you're
saying i can emotionally tolerate that
that's one discussion another discussion
though is what is the
fastest route to wealth
regardless of risk tolerance
okay
what's the fastest route to wealth and
and you know and within that then okay
we've got to discuss can i stomach that
with my risk tolerance do i have enough
risk tolerance to go
that route the fastest surest
route to wealth not just
and most likely so
i would go back to something like
the 10 167 millionaires we studied
and the number of them that said because
i had a high risk tolerance i kept a
mortgage the whole time and i invested
all the money
and uh today i have a million dollars in
mutual funds
i have two million dollars in mutual
funds and i owe
600 000 on my house
the number of them that said that was
less than 10 percent
90 plus percent
i got my house paid off and i dumped
everything in mutual funds in my 401
case
okay so
the practical facts are
the
the normative way the most likely way
the highest probability way according to
the data to bill wealth is to invest
into mutual funds and to get the house
paid off
um
instead of because otherwise you would
say you would say all right i'm going to
borrow as much as i can borrow on the
house all the time and every so often
i'm going to refinance it and throw all
that money with the cash out into the
and stay mortgaged up to my eyeballs
yeah if the concept worked you would do
that but the problem with that is is
that it affects other things in the
unseen and that is is that the borrower
slave to the lender you make different
decisions in your life when you don't
have a house payment
about your career yeah
it puts different stresses on your
relationships
it you treat you know your children
different there's different levels of
health issues when there's no debt
versus if there's debt regardless of
risk tolerance all of those things end
up applying out there in the real world
yeah i keep going back to the car you
said you're you sold your car to an
investor
do you need it so no
no i don't that actually that was just
uh i sold i i was able to sell my car it
was a honda a 2008 honda fit i sold it
for 300 more than i bought it for uh
five years ago and so i bought an
electric bike and i take that to work
i'm only three miles from work
um the problem is i do live in you know
florida so i'm gonna start sweating here
soon um but no the that's just i just my
wife and i felt like we've got our 2015
minivan and like we can be a one car
family okay um okay yeah so that that
was more well i guess i'm just i'm
having a little bit of trouble wrapping
my mind around the math of it but maybe
i need to let that you know i don't
think it
here's the okay the math here's how the
math works all right in
graduate level
studies
in finance
or maybe even in a good school in the
senior year level um we are taught to
christina and i were taught to
analyze two different mutual funds
okay an aggressive growth stock mutual
fund has a measure of risk called a beta
the higher the beta the higher the risk
the higher the peaks and valleys if you
chart it the more volatile it is okay
high beta more risk okay
low beta less risk and so you take an
aggressive growth with a bay a high beta
and uh maybe a maybe a 2.5 beta or
something like that and then you take a
growth in income that might have a 0.8
beta
less than one
beta a one beta is the s p 500 what the
market does just to give you an example
okay so here's how the math works if
you're if you in order to compare those
two they have different volatility so
comparing them apples to apples is naive
you see what i'm saying sure so you've
the way you mathematically adjust for it
is there's an inverse formula where the
beta is flipped on its head with in an
inverse fraction so that the beta
reduces the higher beta reduces the
return
of the of the risky investment and the
lower beta
raises the return of the lower
investments so that after adjusted for
risk mathematically you can compare
these apples to apples does that make
any sense
it does i knew you were smarter than i
was and so yeah that that well it's just
it's just what i was taught academically
it's not i'm not yet
but so so the thing is what what has
never happened though we're taught that
in the financial world christina but
we're not taught
to do that with debt
and so we compare
a house with a mortgage equally to a
house without a mortgage
or an investment a property with a
mortgage equally to an investment
property without a mortgage and we do
not apply the increased risk
of beta
to the math formula
and so our that's what i mean by real
estate people their risk meter is broken
they don't analyze for risk and we don't
re and we don't mathematically adjust
for risk and so when we add the beta
idea or concept to your question it says
you are taking more risks so we should
put a higher beta on your plan a lower
beta on my plan and when we risk adjust
mathematically
our plans are going to be fairly equal
okay
that's helpful i really appreciate it
cool i don't know if that made any sense
or not something like a barrel fish
hooks but it is it is the truth that's
the academic way of approaching it the
spiritual way of approaching it is the
borrower is slave to the lender 100 of
the references in the bible to debt say
debt is stupid it's not a sin you're a
slave you're a fool you're impulsive it
always says that so if the bible says
and i'm a christian if the bible says
negative things about death it doesn't
say it's a sin doesn't say i'm going to
hell if i get a mastercard it's not a
salvation issue but but if spiritually
my heavenly father is saying in his
handbook there's nothing good about debt
then i have to read that and believe it
if i'm a person of faith
absolutely and then i can also go over
here and use my brain and use a beta and
either way i come to the same conclusion
yep that's such a great way of meshing
those two things together
yeah it's uh
but but the you know i actually um
was speaking to a graduate level group
at uh vandy one time and walked them
through that on the math idea and
they're like looking at me like i've
never heard that before i'm like well
it's because nobody teaches it nobody
talks about debt equals risks or you
need to factor a beta into it a measure
of risk mathematically into it and when
you put in a measure of risk
mathematically into it it takes away the
advantages of debt and guess what we all
know that because when you're debt-free
you build wealth faster so duh
you know that's kind of the way this
whole thing works it's an interesting
discussion i appreciate his question
that's great christina ellis ramsey
personality james childs our producer
and uh zach and kelly also in the booth
i'm dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host christina
ellis ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today this hour
we're going to take your calls about
your life and your money and we're going
to particularly also concentrate on
going to college
debt free it's a financial literacy
month
this month and we're doing a bunch of
things to celebrate financial literacy
around here right now at ramsey we'll be
talking about that through the hour but
if you have questions about college you
have questions about paying off student
loans you have questions about going to
school debt-free this would be your hour
we're going to hold open a couple of
lines just for you guys christina is an
expert in that area for sure
probably knows more about it than
anybody else in this building right now
and uh so we'll take your calls the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
christina is out our latest ramsey
personality to join the team uh she had
a best-selling book before she came here
confessions
of a scholarship winner where she
outlined how she got a half a million
dollars for scholarships
and uh got a degree uh from vanderbilt
university and a follow-up master's
degree from belmont did i get that right
yep okay got it wrong last time i was on
there i got it backwards i had you
getting your masters at vandy i think
last time i mean that's cool too either
way it'll work but except it has the
inconvenient thing of not being true but
yeah so um anyway
you were able to gather up a lot of
scholarship money you wrote a
bestselling book about it and so we know
we have proof positive sitting next to
me that you can go to college on
scholarships but there's a lot of other
things that enter into you going to
school debt-free or sending your kid to
school
debt-free it's first it begins with a
mindset
yep absolutely i'm so thankful my
freshman year of high school my mom had
a real conversation with me about money
and the realities of what i'd be
responsible for after graduation you
know a lot of students they get to
senior year and the first person they
talk to about money with is somebody
trying to sell them a student loan and
that's just not okay they haven't had a
lot of experience with debt or running a
budget or anything like that and so it's
so important to have these money
conversations early on like we want
parents to be the first people talking
to their kids about money yeah and
talking to them with a different mindset
the mindset is okay
let's just draw a line in the sand we're
not borrowing money for college period
end of statement
now
how do we go to college
okay and uh there's three or four things
that enter into it at that point
a
you're probably working
you didn't have to you got a half
million dollars in scholarships but most
of us when we were in college we worked
and it's not child abuse
and your snowflake won't melt they can
go to school in fact it's good for you
there's actually studies that say that
students who work while they're in
college are actually more successful
academically i think having that
discipline of having to show up and have
structure to your schedule is a good
thing on many levels yeah i was talking
to a
a a
college coach the other day i was having
breakfast with a college coach and he
was saying that
assuming the student has gray matter you
know uh that they that the uh that the
athletes typically have a higher
gpa
um because they also have to manage
their time uh because they're they have
a job it's called being an athlete and
it takes up a lot of time it versus
people like me that went to school and i
all i did was go to school and work and
and then people that don't even work
they just play beer pong i mean it's
just you know it just goes downhill and
so um you know
this idea that you're that you're not
going to be able to get through school
if you work is ridiculous i worked 40 to
60 hours a week when i was in school and
i got through in four years
so i mean it i lived off campus it can
be done it can be done but um i mean i
was a little business nerd i was a
little
you know had my little time management
system
i'm selling real estate you know 18
years old i mean i was way you know i
was an old man in a little kid's body
but um
but the but but so that's different i
understand that i and i don't want to be
a nerd like that well i know but i don't
want you to be 200 000 in debt either so
maybe work is good okay and you get
experience so you walk away from college
with that much more experience under
your belt a lot of employers one of the
first things they ask what's your
experience and it's like you've already
got that done while you're in college
yeah and well and you've you know you've
experienced some workplace things where
you go you know what i don't work for
that guy people act like that i don't
want to be around somebody treats me
that way and so when you're going for an
interview you can kind of smell that a
little bit you know and you pick a
better job than if you're just going
cold and everything looks wonderful
because i don't know anything right so
yeah working is good
um
getting scholarships is good
and uh you talk about that of course a
lot it is uh one of the key elements of
uh
your uh expertise as you came to us and
so talk about how to get scholarships
yeah well i won over a half a million
dollars in scholarships going into
college and man i treated it like a
part-time job when i was in high school
i mean when you do the math on the
amount of money i earned per hour it was
completely worth it i was making over
like a thousand dollars per hour when
you factor in how many hours i put into
applications versus how much money i got
so you know if a student spends two
hours spilling out an application and
they win a thousand dollars that's like
making 500 per hour where else can you
make that kind of money in high school
so i encourage people to really take
this process seriously start as soon as
you can it's hard though it is hard you
have to scratch and claw and dig them up
and they're more rare i think than they
used to be now do you think yep i mean
there's a lot of them but you just have
to really just cipher through them and
uh decide which ones are the real ones
which one which ones apply to you
some of them are just click bait they're
just trying to get you trying to get
your name and stuff they're just trying
to collect you and pull you into a sofa
student loan or something right yeah a
lot of them are what they call
sweepstakes scholarships which is
basically like a marketing ploy they're
trying to get your email so they can
sell you something else and i usually
recommend either avoid those or don't
take them as seriously
whenever you're filling out scholarship
applications i recommend you get a
separate email address because some of
them can send you quite a bit of spam
but make sure you actually check that
email address because i've talked to
several scholarship programs who have
actually given out a scholarship and the
person didn't follow up they didn't
check their email they weren't on top of
it so
with every step in this process i want
you to be very intentional
be intentional about building your
resume throughout high school so one of
the beautiful things about my mom
telling me freshman year of high school
that i was on my own for college was i
started thinking about scholarships my
freshman year so i started reading a
bunch of books and just interviewing
alumni from my high school asking what
did you do to stand out in the
scholarship application process and i
learned that a lot of them took on
leadership roles they were super
involved in extracurricular activities
they volunteered and so i started
thinking through you know what can i do
to stand out in the application process
none of your scholarships were academic
or athletic
that they factored in because
merit-based scholarships they factor in
those elements right but it wasn't
because you were like a valedictorian
right right my test scores were not the
best i was not the top in my class and
that's one of the encouragements i give
to people is that you don't have to be
perfect to win scholarships when you
really think about it the people who
give out scholarships it can be anyone
so there are people who literally had b
averages and went on to be successful
and now they've created scholarships for
people with b averages so it's like
there are scholarships given away for
almost anything and everything you gotta
find the ones that fit you you're
actually talking about me
i have a 2.97 average and i give out
scholarships so
okay all right i'll just go with that
okay
oh i love it christina ellis ramsey
personalities my co-host it's a
financial literacy theme now we're
talking about going to college without
any debt you want to talk about it we'll
let you in right now the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
christina one thing that we all share in
common uh older young
regardless of the region of the country
you're from almost every one of us can
point back
in our years and see a teacher's face
that changed our life
that impacted the trajectory of our life
teachers are a big deal so part of our
financial literacy month to celebrate
our high school curriculum being in
about 50 percent of the high schools 48
of the high schools in america teaching
our high school curriculum right now
part of the way we're celebrating that
is a teacher appreciation giveaway we're
giving away five thousand dollars to two
different teachers in cash
you do not have to be teaching our
curriculum to win you do have to be a
actual teacher not like i taught my dog
to sit that's not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about you actually teach
like in a classroom and stuff
people get confused about these things
we have to clarify but um and so if
you're a homeschool teacher and you have
one child you're not a teacher that's
not what we're talking about i
appreciate you doing that that's a
wonderful thing that's your choice
that's cool i'm talking about teachers
in the classroom
and this is who we want to give this
might do we want to say thank you to you
guys five thousand dollars and then
we're gonna give three more teachers a
thousand dollars each the
giveaway will happen in just a couple of
days on april the 30th
and so you need to go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher you teachers do no purchase is
necessary and register and this is
brought to you by the documentary that
just won the number one documentary this
year on by the webby awards
and that is our documentary on student
loan debt called borrowed future
borrowed future all right our question
of the day comes from
blinds.com blinds.com has a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from rebecca in
pennsylvania i have two kids both in
high school
one it's college bound but i don't
believe the other is is it fair that we
pay for school for one while the other
doesn't get anything
gosh that's a tricky question but i i
personally would say that it is
especially if that money was
specifically set aside for education and
you've been very clear about that you
know obviously you need to talk to both
kids and give them both the equal
opportunity to get an education but if
one chooses not to
then you know ultimately that's their
decision however i would also make sure
to talk to that kid about their
educational options you know college
it's not the only way to get educated
perhaps your other child might want to
go to a trade school or vocational
school and you can help them with that
and kind of just encourage them along
the way and set them up for success yeah
i uh uh
uh fair is where cotton candy and the
tilt-aware are okay
fair is not fair is not equal equal is
not fair
if i work twice as many hours as you
work
i should get paid twice what you get
paid
if i'm a doctor and i went to school for
43 years
and you got out of the 8th grade and i
make six hundred thousand dollars a year
and you make six thousand dollars a year
that's fair
that's fair
a doctor should they they paid a price
they have a higher level of education a
higher level of expertise the culture
the services that they provide we the
culture value that hire it doesn't mean
the human being is a better human being
sometimes it means the opposite it
doesn't mean that one person is worth
more than another person i'm talking
about economics fair is not equal and
equal is not fair
socialism and communism is the only
place that attempts to happen and it
doesn't even work there
because it turns out the people running
the communist country have all the money
hello so it's not even fair or equal
there either so let's just be clear
about that so once we say all of that
then we say all right
now how do we apply that to this
question that fair is not equal
i would have a tendency to say
let me ask you if you believe this
because you've studied this more than i
have you've done a lot of work in this
area
it feels like to me in today's world
that some
post
high school education
would greatly increase your chances of
success
whether it's trade school
uh whether it's tech
and you're doing some kind of mentoring
or apprentice program
or whether it's a four-year
academic
degree in a useful area of study of this
area that's useful but i i mean if
you're going to be a farmer you ought to
learn more about farming than they teach
in high school right but you may not
need a four-year degree in agriculture
right okay i'll go along with that all
right uh so but but i think you got to
have a knowledge level above a high
school level
uh and even people who are hugely
successful who are high school graduates
only they went and gathered knowledge
somehow somewhere in addition to high
school you you see what i'm saying is
you feel like
in your experience is there any data
that lines up with that right yeah
that's the thing is it's like there's a
lot of disruption in higher education
right now especially post code a lot of
people are questioning is a four-year
degree worth it and the thing is is it
may or may not be for you but education
is still worth it like you said
it's still key to get an education you
know in whatever you do whether it's a
certificate program or a vocational
degree getting educated to do your job
well is important i know you said
earlier you know don't throw out the
baby with the bathwater just because
there's a student loan crisis and things
are really being disrupted right now
doesn't mean people shouldn't get
educated in one shape or form but they
should do it debt-free and figure out
what's really going to be useful for
their career path yeah so in this case
you got one going to college you're
going to help them with it i'm going to
encourage the other one to do something
right and i will help them with that
it might not cost as much
i might spend half as much on their
trade school to be a welder as i spend
on the one over here getting the
four-year degree so fair's not equal
equals not fair but i am going to push
both of them to a life of continuous
learning
because very you know we tell people
around here all the time i have people
interviewing for a leadership degree or
leadership position here at ramsey and
i'll ask them you know what's the latest
book you read and they have to think
three seconds i don't if you're not
reading you don't need to be leading
right you need to be reading if you're
going to lead absolutely readers or
leaders leaders or readers i mean
there's just no you have to be reading
something because your brain has to be
jacked up
and your brain goes to sleep watching
netflix crap you know your brain just
shuts off and starts to deteriorate like
you're smoking dope or something i mean
it's just so you have to read
you have to read
and so in other words a continuous
learning life is
part of the success formula whether or
not it is higher education we can say
that's okay right well and i think some
parents they get frustrated when they
hear their students say you know i don't
want a four-year degree and then they
kind of lose that spot of influence in
their students lives because they're
just pushing pushing pushing for one
route but it's like if you really stop
and listen and say what is your passion
what do you want to do and then you help
them map out that journey to get there
you know you can help them find that
right education process for them yeah
but i mean i know a young man that um
you know had a yard cutting business in
high school
and he went and got a two-year
associate's degree in um horticulture or
whatever
and uh you know continued to grow his
landscaping business and then took some
business classes and you know came to
entre leadership and he runs a big
stinking business
you know a big bit very successful way
more successful than you know
financially and otherwise than a lot of
people who get useless four-year degrees
so you know and that's a very low-tech
uh trade school type thing i mean in
welders right now a good welder's making
100k a good diesel mechanic's making
100k
so uh i'm okay with that so i'm going to
take junior that's not going to college
and say hey
nothing is not a plan
right something and we'll help you with
the something let's figure out what that
is the bible says train up a child and
when he is old he will not depart from a
chain of child in the way is bent the
old testament the old new old king james
says and the way the child is bent the
way the child is designed
and so if you've got one that's designed
for the trades then let them go into the
trades but but but i got to be the best
at it
right you know there's a reason they're
starving artists they suck
well they need that mentor try not
sucking at your trade right and then you
won't be starving at it that's just you
know that's the thing right i don't care
what you want to do but just go be the
best at it and you can always make a
living being the top five percent of
something right so get after it baby
yeah so equals not fair fair is not
equal
but continuous learning is a necessary
part of successful living it's good
there we go there's some principles to
go with this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we do a financial literacy theme hour
we're celebrating our foundations and
personal finance curriculum that has
been taught in 48 of america's
classrooms
if you have a high school classroom and
you'd like to get that into your
classroom please
contact us we'd love to help you do that
sometimes we even have local businesses
that will pay for your school
and pay for it for your school and if
you're a local business and you want to
hey my old high school needs to teach
this stuff well you're right it does and
why don't you furnish it for them that'd
be an awesome thing for you to do to
give to your community that way all of
that can be done at ramseysolutions.com
get in touch with our team here the
ramsey ed team
we put the high school curriculum middle
school curriculum
we have uh college curriculum all
teaching the financial principles that
we teach celebrating all of that today
we're doing a teacher appreciation
giveaway awarding two teachers five
thousand dollars go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher that is
brought to you by the film
borrowed future our documentary on the
epic
failure of the student loan crisis in
america christina is actually featured
in that documentary before she came to
work here she was one of our featured
experts on the student loan crisis
teachers if you want to screen
that documentary on the evils of student
loans for your team
they can watch borrowed future in your
classroom for free
we will not charge you a dime to show it
to your students
and it just won the number one webby
just this week we got a big award on it
and so go to borrowedfuture.com contact
us if you're a teacher we'd love to do
that for you
and it is so rewarding to have these
teenagers learning this material keith
is with us keith is in colorado springs
keith you got a question about going to
college
yes uh my son's eight years old and i
was just trying to get the what's the
best strategy for
uh putting money away for his college or
education
yeah we definitely recommend a 529 plan
there's a lot of tax benefits it's a
great vehicle for education
you can use it for k-12 and also for
college
we actually were talking about earlier
we do not recommend using it for student
loans but it can even be used to pay off
ten thousand dollars in student loans so
the things that you can do related to
education with the 529 are just really
great there's also an esa
there's income limits around it but
that's another great spot to save for
college yeah always use good growth
stock mutual funds not prepaid college
in the 529
and uh and you know you can set it up
with your smart investor pro click smart
investor at ramsey solutions dot com
they'll set up an automatic draft you
can put 50 100 200 a month into it and
uh and be sure that you're ahead the
other thing i would do
as a parent
who has now uh my youngest is 30 years
31 years old
um all three of my children went to a
four-year university all three graduated
debt-free i paid for it and all three
graduated in four years which is
sometimes known as a miracle um
and the reason that happened was we
didn't wait until they were leaving to
go to college to start talking about
this
we started talking about the importance
of education when they were eight
and we started talking about using sense
common sense with your education
and so you're going to go to a school
that makes sense economically you're
going to study something that is usable
in the marketplace uh ramses are
utilitarian meaning we actually want
some value for what we spend
we're not uh aesthetics we don't just
gather up uh
degrees to feel good about ourselves
uh we gather up degrees to get the
knowledge to go win in the marketplace
and christina you said something
at the break that i think is good as a
parenting conversation so keith i'm
saying take the eight-year-old begin to
train them
talk to them about the importance of
their grades now
that study habits turn into
life habits
that study habits turn into grades which
give you access to good schools at
lesser cost right and you can st you
need to start talking about that one
when they're eight right well it's it's
interesting i talked to a lot of parents
who have seniors and they were you know
i'm giving a presentation about
scholarships and talking about getting
involved in extracurricular activities
and all these different things and they
say you know how do i motivate my senior
in high school and i'm i start asking
them questions about you know what have
they been doing what activities are they
involved in what do they do and they're
like uh they mostly you know play video
games or kind of lay around and it's
like
it's kind of hard to instill that
motivation now a lot of that starts when
they're eight it's you know it's going
out and volunteering as a family it's
getting them involved in extracurricular
activities talking to them about college
and the future and helping them start to
have ownership over
their future and their responsibilities
that conversation starts early
yeah to my knowledge um
the
scholarships awarded to video gamers is
fairly limited
i mean
they probably do have video game
scholarships i think they do but i think
they're pretty limited right i think
they're pretty limited yeah i'm thinking
halo that'll get you in you know but oh
my gosh well it's interesting i even
give an example where it's like if you
love video games there's nothing wrong
with that but be intentional with it so
you could even like start an online
community with other video gamers host a
local group where you bring people
together and talk about things you can
turn everything into a positive you're
so nice
i'm just going don't be a deadbeat
don't be sitting on the couch eating
doritos playing video games and expect
you'll be a success in your life okay
come on real
make the most of your passions yes
you're something else that's amazing
well done you said something at the
break that i also want to visit back for
keith's benefit as we talk about
parenting
youngsters towards an education
um and i think this is where society has
created the epic student loan failure
off this one comment this one phrase i'm
gonna steal it i'm gonna use it over and
over and over again because it's so good
um
it's what it's what's caused this whole
discussion around higher education and
to tell the audience what you and i were
talking about the break yeah we're
talking about how college has become
decoupled from reality so a lot of
people feel like even
that was a mic drop
college has become decoupled
from reality
see that's how you go spend 250 000
to get a master's degree in sociology to
make 38 000 worth of state as a
caseworker because you are deca coupled
from freaking reality your parents are
you are your counselor is your congress
is and now you have a mess in your life
that decoupled from reality that's
that's good we need to recouple yes
i was watching a video the other day
where the person was talking about how
we wouldn't give an 18 year old 150 000
business loan oh that guy's funny that's
a comedian right he's like yeah i think
i need 150 000 so for the next four
years i can stay slam drunk that was his
line it's hilarious and you're gonna
you're gonna bar you know what banker's
gonna loan this guy money oh we are it's
called student loans right oh my gosh
right yeah it's like you see these
people who are normally responsible even
parents who are normally responsible and
have you know their money figured out
and then their kid goes to college and
then they let them take out forty
thousand dollars in student loans or a
hundred thousand dollars in student
loans and it's like you wouldn't you
wouldn't do that in another scenario you
wouldn't let them take out a personal
loan they wouldn't loan you a hundred
thousand dollars to buy a ferrari when
you're 18.
right uh so why do we loan you a hundred
thousand dollars to go to vanderbilt i
mean my god
it's the same stupid stuff
oh ferraris go down in value but so is
your vanderbilt education oh my god this
is unbelievable well and some of it like
it's not even centered around like what
are they actually going to do with that
four-year degree like i love that you
use left-handed puppetry but it's like
they'll take out a hundred thousand
dollars in student loans for a degree
that's not really focused on what they
want to do and so it's like there's just
kind of a in
in a lot of senses a lack of
intentionality well it's an expensive
way to find yourself yeah oh my god i
need to find myself well let's not go on
a journey that cost 200 grand to find
yourself let's just drop you in the
amazon see if you can get out oh my gosh
well and that's part of why borrowed
future is so powerful because it shows
the reality of that it's like hey wait a
minute these are these there's a lot of
people in that documentary who were told
you know get a degree no matter the cost
it's all going to work out and it's like
wait a minute but you guys need to hear
this that is there's insight in that
statement right there
we have decoupled
education from reality
the parents
the students
the educators in higher education
and the congress who loans them the
money
and me by god the taxpayer they funded
it
we have decoupled it from reality and
that's where all this level of disgust
comes in we're disgusted with it it's
ridiculous i would fire somebody that
acted that way if they work for me
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
it's a financial literacy theme hour
here on the ramsey show our scripture
today is proverbs 14 23 in all toil
there is profit but mere talk
tends only to poverty thomas edison said
opportunity is missed by most because it
is dressed in overalls and looks like
work
there we go kind of been a theme today
all day long all right up next is
valerie in san antonio hey valerie
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um i just needed some i guess financial
advice um
real quick synopsis
widowed in 15.
i remarried last year
i have four
children remaining in the household that
are mine
from the previous marriage
husband had no children we just had a
newborn
about six weeks ago we're trying to
still figure out how
to
merge assets together um i had over 700
000
of more equity assets he had
liquid um i guess like um
cash flow
for lots of better work since i don't
work
um about 150 of retirement
and we still can't figure out i think a
lot of the arguments is
a lot of financial aspects because it's
kind of penny pinching each other
because we don't want to join him
together we don't want to you know i
don't want it to be unfair for him with
four additional children and he doesn't
want to be impaired for me you know feel
like he's you know feeding off of us um
i paid uh i bought a house in cash 555
thousand
um i took a small
noise on it all right how old are you
how old are you
i'm i'm 38. how old is he
he's 38. what's his income
his incomes about
87.
okay
all right
he knew you had four
he knew you had four children when he
married you right
well i actually have seven yes before
they're living with me he knew you had
four children that he was going to be
helping to raise
the rest of the way
they come with a package didn't he
in equity but had a good income didn't
you
i did this is what you both signed up
for
combine it and shut up
okay you want the marriage to be you
want the marriage to be right or you
want to keep your stuff
i wanted to be right yeah that's what i
think
and that's why i'm being so harsh with
you okay
because here's the thing you guys are
you know if you want to back up and do
some kind of pre-nup but i think it'd be
ridiculous on our post enough or
whatever you call those things i think
it'd be ridiculous on this amount of
money i i think that you love him he's
committing his
the next decade of his life to finish
raising your last four and pouring a lot
of his income into it while you stay at
home you're committing your equity to
this situation uh and the two of you
love each other and you're going to
spend the rest of your lives together
you're only 38 when you're 88 and it's
been 50 years and you look back
all of this should have been melded
together shouldn't it
yeah
i think so it's the only way it's going
to work
and so if if he thinks he's some kind of
cool dude because he brings an income or
you think you're some kind of cool chick
because you got some equity
then you two are going to be at each
other the rest of your lives
okay am i wrong
i i hope you're not because
i it's not working the way we're doing
now because something has to change yeah
i agree
so here's what here's what i'm
perceiving from the outside and and i'm
being kind of smart alec with you and
tough on you but what i'm perceiving
from the outside is
that you guys need to flip what it is
that you think is most important
my observation of people who have high
quality marriages and build wealth over
all these years over these tens of
thousands of people i've worked with is
that they put their relationship ahead
of their money
and you guys are putting your money
ahead of your relationship
makes sense okay
is that fair well
is that yeah i think it is yeah it is
just a lot of influence
it could go bad it could go bad
but guess what if it goes bad four years
from now the judge is going to give you
all your equity back
because you owned it prior to the
marriage
you're in texas
okay he's not he's not gonna give half
of your stuff after four years of
marriage to your to your husband okay
he's just not gonna do it now after 30
years of marriage yeah probably
but if it goes bad soon
the law accounts for
your concerns
i'm not a lawyer but sadly i've
been and
had the opportunity to walk through
a lot of these situations with folks who
were going through divorce so
um but but you have to decide what it is
you value more
let's concentrate on that and that means
the other is going to take back seat
and so you guys are trying to say all
right the money's the most important
thing and how do i do that and still
have a quality relationship very
difficult
yeah that's so well said i think it's a
mindset shift for sure it's it's going
from this is his money this is my money
too it is our money and we're doing this
together now we always tell young
couples and you guys aren't uh you're
not baby children i mean you're not 21
or something but
um
we always tell young couples you have to
be french once you're married we we we
we we own stuff our stuff you don't have
my stuff your stuff our stuff
and um
you know my wife has not earned an
income outside of the home in over 30
years
but we have a wonderful income
because we're french we
right i mean that's a big deal yeah and
so
um you know and you know and we have to
be real careful because sometimes she'll
go well you know
you're making all this money no no no no
no no we are making all this money i
happen to be the one down there at the
office but we are making all this money
it is our money there's a we here and
you have to really work on that and work
on your pronouns because out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
the bible says
so uh we tell folks that come to work
here don't talk about they or you guys
you're a we once you're here and when
you don't want to be a wee anymore go
work somewhere else because we as we
and same thing working here you change
your pronouns when you're ramsey on the
ramsey team you're we
we this is we don't do it that way we
we believe this we
and we'll argue with each other we argue
about what we think you know inside this
building and you do that in your
marriage too if you're smart so um it's
a good question valerie and your you
know your your how you got here is
reasonable
but as you said what you're doing is not
working
and you may want to do this under the
guidance of a good marriage counselor or
a good pastor walking you through it's
not like you're about to get divorced
but there is a rough patch here and
having somebody help you put language to
it might be really really really
valuable
all right it is a financial literacy
theme hour we're celebrating our
foundations and personal finance class
being in about 48 of the high schools in
america we're appreciating teachers with
the teacher appreciation giveaway two
more days the giveaway ends april 30th
five thousand dollars to two teachers
cash will be given away
no purchase necessary you don't have to
be teaching our curriculum you have to
be a teacher go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher it's brought to you by the
documentary borrowed future
and in the one minute that we've got
left
the most important thing if you want to
go to school debt free
the most important mathematical variable
is
college choice
choosing a school that you have the
money to pay for
vanderbilt is fifty four thousand
dollars a year tuition
the university of tennessee is twelve
thousand dollars a year tuition plus
room and board in both cases okay
nothing wrong with either university you
went to vanderbilt i went to the
university of tennessee we can argue
about that later but the uh but but no
neither one are bad neither one are evil
neither one are inherently good
uh neither one of us are better for
having gone one place or the other place
it's a college
you were able to pay cash for that with
scholarships i was able to pay cash for
the university of tennessee with hard
work
um either one's okay but adjust your
college choice to fit your budget you
cannot buy a bentley when you're 18
years old if you have the budget for a
used chevy pickup
buy a used chevy pickup
number one problem that causes student
loans is students decouple
the college cost from reality and go i
can just go anywhere because it's
education and math doesn't count yes it
does count
go where you can afford that's simple
good show christina great being here
this is fun it was a lot of fun good day
today all right to james and kelly and
zach and the gang in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you